hello guys my name is Greg and I'm Jenny
Kuwait chebika way my brother
javi cool a we're gonna watch a couple
little teasers for the official trip
that's going to drop off Saturday got so
many requests and do this chef a he
lives right next door to me now so I
invited him over to come do this unite
the lead trailers one for Batman and one
for Aquaman I'm just giving you guys a
heads up I might be a little late to
doing the official trailer because I
have an event to go to on Saturday
stripclub
[Laughter]
important that's important and that's it
up and Justice League will have to wait
all right I'll start with Aquaman I'm
sure these will you look so much
information and that's why you guys
wanted us to watch
you got em
oh so worth it what it's like sister
costumes
we added teasers for teasers man because
no one's going to watch the trailer and
let they see it is one partnership well
I mean you're building up hype which is
this is this is obviously a new trend
and clearly it's working because they
keep doing this were they they give a
trailer to the trailer
yeah just to amplify the excitement
behind it and get buzz going well you
know Batman was handing Aquaman is
trying to do one of those things where
people make theories based off nothing
Batman was handing Aquaman is trite in
there what do you think that's about why
is it called the Trident instead of a
quadrant if it's got four things
honestly I might have gotten it wrong I
don't know what I mean it's called it
these things are typically called a tri
didn't like I'm going up a little
mermaid when I hear the words riding I
mean Aquaman looks really cool though I
mean it's cool that better than matched
bringing the life that make it look
cheesy if it eats business in the DC EU
he does look pretty cool and went how
many shots are going to be where tidal
waves are coming at him he just stands
there honey pass him I don't imagine
that many I think that's just an
introduction or no actually that well no
they always welcome at the end of the
movie look towards words they like
climactic action sequence where he
stuffs at all well they have that one
shot where he's standing shirtless and
then they have another shot where he's
fully suited and it's coming at him
right but who knows hey hey ass and I
mean Jami touch the United Elite Batman
one you've heard of Batman right once or
twice yeah
played famously by Val Kilmer
oh whoa what was he shooting at oh we
gotta slow these images down does anyone
else feel like they're being manipulated
by me I just figured that man like weird
humor between the two trailers it's like
oh here's a little bit more of that one
shot I just I filled it strange that's
why the film oh yeah of course
and it's totally working I love how like
every trailer for Justice League now
they're trying to show that man has a
sense of humor this time around see how
we look look over there is kind of funny
I like how Ben Affleck looks here better
than in venom vs. Superman you mean even
older even older like he's got he's got
wrinkles in his forehead and you got
beer going on obviously it's not keeping
the beard when he's in full costume but
he looks older as a character and I
think that's cool what is that statue
he's standing on I mean I don't know
anything about like Darkseid Steppenwolf
in the garden all that crap you know I
just wear all these clothes that get
sent to me to make it look like I'm I'm
a huge comic book reader I just gained a
lot of subs by saying that what's he
shooting at my age in England you can go
frame by frame with the arrows because
that goggles oh he's like shooting out
one of the gargoyles Oh from like one of
the I mean that's what it looks like
yeah and it looks like one of those
we're going like a machine Guardians up
from like from the dream she was having
about the pair of demons and BBS yeah so
it's coming to life it's linking BBS is
a better movie now because it connects
ethically oh hopefully hopefully what
has all that has done and you see all
the films finally you know completed it
all feels like it's cohesive as opposed
to arbitrary yeah I think it's just kind
of coming out of nowhere you know and
will look back and be like wow and he
was a genius and Hydra knew what he was
doing the entire time they showed an
official like image of the door all the
way down of all the Justice League
standing there I like that mint costume
and Aquaman comfortable out there it
looks pretty cool yeah they both they
all look really cool Wonder Woman that
she's going to make like a billion and a
half dollars that woman Calgon odd and
damn she's gonna make so much money this
is here and no one
cares about cyborgs but he isn't in any
way you look with Trevor Noah
today yeah it's not because he's black
all right dude you genuinely look like
your vanilla journalist likes Trevor
Noah and I could be off the mat for
Halloween okay it's gotta do some
push-ups I'll be bickering oh I guess
you could yeah I mean sure all right
well you can subscribe to the real
rejects hey click that notification bell
got a little note here to do that jab
Iike waves on the jab eco a channel
their profession go to jab you tube if
you want to see videos early reactions
and movie reviews and whatnot the
American style American style can't you
just put like the playlist of your jab
etude stuff on the jab equal a camel I
used to have it and then you guys
separate platelets for that it just
makes sense to have super channel so
I've got the American channel and the
international channel the International
League Bollywood Korean cinema Japanese
cinemas international ones huge and
blowing up it gives way more views than
a lot of us a lot of us out there damn
foreigners